okay good evening
uh councillors ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to this virtual meeting of
council
um father gerald murphy can't be with us
this evening
i just want to read out um a brief
reflection
can i say to all members of council that
we conduct this meeting in a positive
fashion
that we treat each other with respect
and dignity
and we discuss these matters of the
budget this evening with the best
interest of all our trafford council
residents in mind the next item is
apologies
all members of council have been invited
to attend this meeting electronically
and have received apologies from the
councils are there any other apologies
this evening
no there's no other apologies
okay we'll record the council assurance
center apologies
um i first remind you of a few of the
house rules when in
participating in tonight's virtual
meeting
please remember to mute your microphone
when not speaking
to use the chat facility to indicate to
the chair that you wish to speak
and please only use the chat facility
for this purpose
to unmute your microphone when invited
to speak
by the chair
voting also tonight on those items where
a vote is called
for we will use the polling option at
the appropriate time
i will announce that i am putting the
matter to the vote
a window will appear on your screen and
you'll be asked to click
on one of three options available either
for
against or stain once you have selected
your preference
please click submit at the bottom of the
window and the
of the vote will appear on the screen
once all votes
are in finally since we are hosting the
meeting virtually
should we encounter any tech that is
it may be necessary to adjourn the
meeting in the first instance
for 15 minutes an update and any
rejoining instructions will be emailed
to members
if we are unable to broadcast the
meeting live on youtube
we would hope to upload a recording at a
later date
okay can i just say to everybody that if
we're not speaking just just just to
move your microphones please
and item number one is the minutes the
first item and i moved at the minutes
of both the extraordinary and ordinary
meetings held on the 27th of january
2021 be taken as a read and signed as a
correct record
is that seconded good mr man
thank you and can i take this
opportunity to say
thank you to the deputy mayor councillor
chris boys
for standing in for me on those meetings
on the 27th
of january item two is announcements
does the leader of the council wish to
make
yeah i'm sorry andrew sorry councillor
weston the leaders moved those miss
are those minutes agreed all
all right thank you everybody item two
does the leader of the council wish to
make any announcement this evening
no thank you mr man thank you
do the chairs of the scrutiny have
anything to announce on behalf of their
committees
no mr mayor
[Music]
thank you uh item 3 designation of
section 151
officer um the designation of the
council section one five officer
and i invite councillor ross the
executive member for finance
and governance to introduce the report
mr mayor um obviously council will be
aware
that nikki will be leaving us at the end
of march
and whilst we are very sorry to see
nikki go and i'll say more of that later
um we do need to replace our section 151
officer which is obviously a key
function of the council so
the proposal is for the section 151
officer to pass from nikki bishop to
graham bentley
thank you councillor ross do any members
wish to speak
counsel weston thank you mr mayor i'm
not sure if i need to
second that or not but regardless i did
want to just come in to ensure that
nikki is suitably humiliated
um as we as we say an official
goodbye to her um tonight i know that i
will speak
for um most if not all members i should
imagine all members when i say that
nikki has been
an absolutely outstanding treasurer for
us here in trafford
and i think you've been with us about
five years nicki but i lose i lose track
of the um
of the years as they sort of roll
together but in that time
i have always found you to be an
outstanding officer
fair diligent committed somebody who
has always had the needs and interests
of the residents of trafford
forefront in their mind and when you
consider that you are the person who
holds the checkbook that is
um something that is incredibly
reassuring
for us all um i've mentioned in
particular though two wider
roles that you've had for us in that
period too because i think it's
important that these are acknowledged
that you've also been a really valued
member of the corporate leadership team
overseeing not just financial systems as
well and of course
the way above the call of duty
service that you gave to um the ccg
in acting as their treasurer too and i
certainly know that um if i was in that
job i would have
no hair left at all so you have come
through that
process better than many people may have
done and if i may say you have left the
ccg finances
in a better place than many would have
as well and so you have faced
unprecedented challenges
um in that but you have been a much
loved and respected colleague as well as
doing a brilliant job for us
um through that time i know that graham
will do
a superb job and there is nobody better
that you could be handing the reins to a
section 151
officer but i just want to say a
personal thank you nikki
and also um to say how much i'll miss
you you have been
amazing for us you're such a lovely
person as well as being absolutely
brilliant at your job
and we all i'm sure wish you all the
very best in your
well-earned if in my view slightly
premature
retirement thank you mr
thank you councillor weston can i think
can i invite
councillor evans to speak please thank
you uh mr mayor
and for once an entire agreement with
councillor weston
uh nikki and thank you for your support
you have given
me and our group over your time here
here at trafford
when i first arrived on auditor accounts
committee still went behind my political
ears
it was nikki i sat next to who explain
the mystery of local government
finance and accounting still a mystery
and it still needs explaining but thank
you for what you did for me nikki
when local suppliers of our council
weren't being paid
on time it was nikki who within 10 days
managed to free up hundreds of thousands
of pounds for traffic businesses
that i think that's probably one of my
best achievements ever helped by you
nikki
just amazing at the time and the team
you assembled to get out the kobe
support grounds
nearly 12 months ago now we were well
ahead of our gm colleagues
and again really making a massive
difference to
residents and businesses across trafford
so i know we'll be in safe handlers with
graham who is equally as helpful and
skilled uh but you will be missed you
will be missed across this
chamber not i've never heard a negative
word about nicki
so thank you for all you have done for
trafford thank you for the service to
trafford
and thank you for the assistance you've
given me over the years so thank you and
just
enjoy it free of all this
thank you councillor evans um councillor
coggins would you like to come in
thank you chair um yeah i i want to
thank nikki as the others have done for
her her massive contribution to the
council over
her time here and these have not been
easy times to run
local government finances and i expect
the responsibility of being a section
151 officer and
is not one that is easily carried and so
it's really appreciated
that you have done that in such
difficult times and
it's i think really crucial that the
council has someone that is absolutely
reliable that is trustworthy and
responsible in this role and nikki and
indeed graham who's taking over i know
meet these criteria remarkably well
and i think it probably helps um us all
especially the executive no doubt sleep
at night to know that
um the council's finances are in such
safe hands
and since i was first elected nikki's
been a huge help to me
and as the as a brand new opposition
group
i made getting on top of to some degree
and understanding
council finance is one of my priorities
and nikki and graham have both been a
huge support
in that and have answered um very
patiently
and and without a moment's patronizing
and very and endless queries and
questions
um and in fact it was uh nikki who i
think read us out on the night that
cancer jerome and i were elected
registered the provisional results that
um
actually was the one who broke us the
news that we would be joining the
council
and although i i wasn't very focused on
on who was giving that news at the time
and so i believe that nikki intends to
spend more time walking um uh
in her retirement and the green group
wishes her all the best with this for a
really well deserved break
and um and really enjoyable next phrase
in in life so um thank you very much and
and good luck to graham
thank you councillor coggins and
councillor new grosh
thank you miss mayor uh nikki
what more can i say that the other three
have not already said but this is
unanimous across all of the groups in
trafford
um i mean i you i have two paragraphs in
the opening of my speech that i'm now
going to cross out
thanking you for your stewardship uh
through the difficult times
the personal assistance you gave me
understanding
uh very complex um
financial data and uh and just
wishing you the best in retirement uh
from us and all the residents that
that you have assisted over the years
and
well yeah i think you're leaving leaving
things in in safe hands with graham
um so thank you sincerely
thank you councilman any other members
wishing to speak
okay can the recommendation be agreed by
council
please hi hi
hi hi hi hi
the main item this evening is the budget
and i am proposing to conduct the
business
as we have done in previous years
introducing the item council ross the
executive member for finance and
governance
will have a maximum of 15 minutes to
make the initial speech
and at the end the leader of the council
will have a further maximum
of 15 minutes to bring the debate to a
close
on behalf of the main opposition
council's myers
will have a maximum of 15 minutes and
then councillor new grosh and councillor
coggins
on behalf of the minority opposition
groups will each have a maximum of 10
minutes
to make their initial speeches during
which they may give notice of any
amendments
before the debate is brought so before
the debate is brought to a close
counsellors coggins new grush and then
councillor evans as leaders of the
opposition groups
will each have a further maximum of five
minutes
immediate before the lead of the council
winds up the debate
therefore with those timings set aside
we will need to aim to conclude the main
debate on the budget by
8 55 pm if there are any amendments they
will be dealt with
in the order and which notice is given
and i will call on
these to be moved without further
comment the seconder and
all other speakers will be limited to
three minutes
any further amendments or debates on the
main motion
will also have a maximum length of three
minutes for speeches
can i remind you that if necessary i may
have to reduce the time
of speeches and the number of speakers
in order to complete the business
may also draw a council's attention to
regulations that require votes on the
budget
to be recorded the polling function will
register each member's vote
and this will be reported in the minutes
do i have the council's consent to
proceed
on this basis hi
[Music]
hi
before council are the executives
recommendations for the budget
agreed at the executive meeting earlier
this evening
these will be moved by the executive
member for finance and governance
council ross i invite you to open
the debate thank you mr mayor
i'm proud to be able to present this
labour administration's third budget
our medium-term financial strategy
treasury management and capital
strategies
before looking ahead to 2122 it would be
remiss of me not to reflect on the vast
amount of change and challenges
trafford council has encountered over
the last 12 months
you may recall that when i put forward
our budget proposals a little under a
year ago
i did raise the projected budget gap
economic uncertainty
and absence of multi-year funding
projections from the government as
challenges for the years ahead
within weeks of setting the budget last
year this country faced one of the
biggest public health crises we've seen
in a century
and an impact on the economy unrivaled
in modern times
from a financial perspective our
estimate suggests that the gross covet
19 financial pressures this current year
are around 51.2 million which is
striking when compared to the overall
revenue budget of 175.52 million
agreed last february
the 51.2 million pound comprises funding
and service pressures during the year
and we have provided regular updates to
colleagues and manage the situation very
closely
there are still a few more weeks of this
year to run but i am proud of the
proactive way
officers continue to work with members
to deliver this current year's budget
covert 19 has also forced the council to
adapt very quickly and respond
to a situation that impacted on our
residents and businesses across the
borough
it's always been a privilege to serve as
a trafford councillor but when i reflect
on how the council responded to the
challenges and uncertainty we face this
year
i am even prouder and here's some of the
reasons why
we have supported almost 2 800
vulnerable residents with long-term
services this year
keeping them safe and well in their
homes and communities
1.8 million healthy school meals have
been served to our children and young
people
almost 1200 re-enablement services have
provided
for vulnerable adults we've supplied
more than 15 000 supermarket vouchers
worth more than 240 000 pounds
to families entitled to free school
meals since the october half term
almost 1400 vulnerable children visits
took place
took place face to face in december 2020
to ensure
our children were safe and well 92
percent of our all our children have
been supported to be in school
helping our children keep up and catch
up with missed education
we have had 1800 colleagues accessing
council systems from home
up from less than 100 in february 2020
so we could keep providing vital
services for our residents and
businesses we have provided 47 000
pounds in grants to 17 community groups
to support digital inclusion
we have distributed 650 laptops to
schools to help those in need
most with digital inclusion and
accessibility
almost 5000 payments to businesses have
been made with a combined value of 46.5
million pounds to help keep them afloat
a further 354 businesses have been
supported through the discretionary
grant scheme
over 6 000 traffic assist applications
have been processed and almost 300 test
and trace payments being made to support
our residents most in need
we have rehoused 316 extremely
vulnerable people
at risk of homelessness with 122
homelessness prevention
64 people have been supported with lead
every night scheme to enable them to
avoid
rough sleeping over 25 000 tons of waste
has been collected from our residence
homes which is 18.5
more than we expected to collect almost
1500 potholes have been repaired since
april 2020
almost 2 000 planning applications have
been determined which will be a key to
building that better in recovery there
have been 98 virtual committee meetings
and one annual council meeting
more than 200 sets of coronavirus
regulations from central government have
been internet
nearing 200 000 online items from our
e-library have been downloaded since
march 2020
which is an increase of 91 for the same
period last year
waterside arts centre's digital work
including the brilliant pride inside
have been viewed over 32 000 times
our fantastic music service has brought
music to hundreds of the borough school
children
via virtual events like the extravaganza
our team at star procurement continue to
lead the way of our social value agenda
we've paid tribute to our armed forces
with four commemorations
we've registered over 1200 births after
lockdown one
was lifted which is double the same
period last year
and in this most difficult of years over
2
300 services funeral services have been
supported by our bereavement support
service
enabling families to lay their loved
ones to rest with dignity
this is just some of the support and
services provided by trafford council at
a time of national crisis
and it underlines how important the role
of local government is in our society
i would like to thank our officers for
the commitment they continue to show the
borough
to the people and businesses of this
borough it's now time to look at the
year ahead 12 months ago we forecast a
budget gap of 13.31 million for 21.22
so early preparation and our
modernization program were going to
components to delivering a balanced
budget
however the impact of covid19 has caused
a financial budget gap for the year
ahead of 25.52 million
this is the biggest gap in finances
we've had to bridge since the start of
austerity
measures over a decade ago
forgive me i just had to mute myself
this is the biggest
set of finances we've had to bridge
since the start of austerity measures
over a decade ago
and it's set to against a cumulative gap
of 217.73 million since 2010.
this has been one of the most
challenging set of circumstances we've
faced and after several executive
workshops the publication of the draft
budget
and a scrutiny review and a public
consultation we believe we are
presenting a budget tonight
that best supports the delivery of our
frontline services
will support our economic recovery
action plan
we'll support the aims of our new
poverty strategy and equality strategy
will contribute towards our carbon
neutral action plan
and will maintain our council tax at the
second lowest in greater manchester
the budget also supports our strategic
priorities of building quality
affordable and social housing
promoting health and well-being creating
successful and thriving places
supporting children and young people
promoting pride in our area
and being green and connected our
council staff continue to be our biggest
asset
and it has been the executive's clear
position throughout the budget process
that we protect our colleagues from the
threats of compulsory redundancies
we've also done our best as an
organization to recognize and celebrate
the achievements of our workforce
throughout a very difficult year
the executive appreciated the feedback
we received for our draft budget through
the
budget scrutiny sessions and have
responded to the scrutiny committee's
report
we also appreciate the feedback we
received from the public consultation
and have been able to make some changes
to our proposals since october
we have also made one late change and i
am now seeking consent from members for
which i'm now seeking consent from
members for this evening
after careful consideration we have
decided to continue
funding city of trees next year this
will mean the use of 80 000 pounds from
our contingency reserves as a one-off
it passes the financial test as the
original proposal was to withdraw
funding for one year only
we have managed to bridge the 25.52
million pound bridge
budget gap through increasing council
tax by 1.99
increasing the adult social care precept
by 3 percent utilizing reserves
and proceeding with a number of savings
and income proposals
bridging the gap has been a careful
balance and i'll look at each element in
turn
the increases in council tax and social
care precept will bring in over five
million pounds worth of revenue to our
budget this year
which will help to fund our essential
frontline services
the government made an assumption as
part of its core spending proposals that
council would put up council tax this
year
and you'll recall that we raised this as
a concern at council last month
sadly the local conservatives did not
support our pleas for the government to
look again at the court spending
calculation
and we remain in a situation where the
council tax is necessary
nevertheless cal trafford's council tax
remains the second lowest in greater
manchester
we have also taken steps to ensure that
everyone in receipt of council tax
support scheme
as at the 31st march will have their
council tax covered in full next year
we have also looked carefully at how we
can utilize our reserves to support the
revenue budget
our analysis suggests that 8.34 million
of our budget gap
is a result of continuing covert 19
pressures
whilst 2.8 million are a consequence of
businesses usual pressures
we have reviewed our reserve position it
has set out in 6.4 of the report
and have applied a prudent amount to
cover the content to
cover the temporary covered pressure and
businesses usual gap
as i have said on previous occasions
traffic reserves have been historically
low
when compared to other local authorities
and we remain committed to replenishing
reserves whenever we have the
opportunity
to do so we'll also proceed with savings
and income proposals worth over 9
million pounds
each proposal has been carefully
considered to best mitigate the impact
on our frontline services
but this is never an easy process to
work through and i'd like to thank my
colleagues for their time
in coming to those decisions in the
executive
delivering a robust budget is one of our
most important roles as council
and that remains true whatever financial
situation we're dealing with
it is fair to say that over a decade of
austerity has made the ability to
balance budgets extremely challenging
and we're forecasting budget gaps of
almost 18 million pounds
across 2022 2022-2024
the work we've undertaken in putting
together this set of budget proposals
coupled with our commitment to replenish
our reserves when possible
has meant that i'm pleased to know that
our section 151 officer
is able to report that the estimates
made for the purposes of this
calculation of this budget are robust
and the level of reserves and balances
are adequate with the general reserve
increasing from seven million pounds to
eight million pounds
turning now to the capital strategy
capital programme and asset investment
strategy
i'm pleased to confirm that we have
increased the amount of funding to our
capital programme for the next year
and full details of our proposals for
the next few years are set out in the
report
our capital program supports the carbon
neutral action plan
with substantial investment through the
mayor's challenge fund to promote
walking and cycling
and a significant investment in parks
and open spaces
including new tree planting schemes
we've also been informed that a 4.3
million pound bid has been agreed to
introduce decarbonization measures
into our operational buildings however
at this late stage an overnight decision
by government regarding how
the highways capital funding has led to
reduction in funding of over 1 million
pounds
this has led to a last minute amendment
to the capital program report agreed by
the executive
the action taken by the government in
respect to this change is a reminder of
why we have to take a prudent
approach to local government finance
turning to our asset investment strategy
members will recall that the
conservatives launched this strategy in
2017 as a cross-party exercise
the strategies provided support to our
revenue budget of 1.67 million in
2018-19
3.12 million in 2019-20 and is forecast
to provide 6.71 million in 2021.
without this additional support to the
revenue budget we would have to make
further cuts to our front line services
the strategy continues to observe a
prudent approach with all proposals
undergoing due diligence
since labour took control of the council
we have reviewed the strategy to
prioritize
socially responsible and green
investments
the strategy also supports our
commitment to regeneration and the
recent acquisition of stratford malin my
own ward
it was one of the factors that helped
draw an additional 17.6 million pounds
to the area
from the future high streets fund the
overall income target for 2021 to 22
is 7.61 million and with it being clear
that the conservatives and liberal
democrat
democrats are against this strategy they
would have to ask themselves where they
would source equivalent funding
or what further cuts they would make
we're also asking the council to approve
the treasury management strategy as set
out in the papers and as recommended by
the accounts nordic
committee finally i would like to thank
our senior leadership team
finance team and graham bentley and
nicki bishop in particular
as we were aware and just said this is
nicki's finest final trafford budget
and although she may be have been
expecting a quiet final year with us and
a gentle handover to her successor
she has experienced anything but this
year has been intense like no more over
and led to a number of emergency
meetings and decisions
i want to wish nikki well for the future
it has been a pleasure working with her
both in opposition and as the executive
member
and i really do hope that she has a
wonderful retirement
i also want to wish graham bentley well
in his new role
we couldn't wish for a safer pair of
hand of hands to take on this position
at a time of continued turbulence
and i know we all look forward to
supporting him
local councils across the country
stepped up this year
to meet the challenges of covid19 this
labour council will continue to support
our local residents
and businesses promote affordable
housing tackle poverty and inequalities
and promote a greener borough whilst
maintaining sound finances
i therefore move the proposals this
evening thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor ross so with that
slight amendment around the city of
trees support um is the motion seconded
yeah it says second that mr mayor i
reserve my comments
for my closing words later thank you
the meeting needs to agree to accept the
alteration
okay can i ask the the meeting to agree
that alterations around the support the
city of trees and
support if you like hi
hi hi hi
everybody's happy with that thank you i
now call upon the shadow executive
member for finance and governance
councilor myers to respond
yes uh thank you mr mayor um
first i'd like to begin by thanking the
corporate leadership team for the work
they do for us
year round uh special thanks are due to
graham bentley as we've already heard to
louise shaw and their teams have had to
deal with a very difficult and demanding
year
and of course as everyone else has
already said special thanks are due to
nikki bishop
who's going to leave the authority next
month i am particularly grateful to
nikki for her support and guidance over
the last five years
and i'd like to wish her a happy
retirement and she's asked me to point
out that it's actually
an early retirement in looking to the
financial picture in the uk there's no
doubt that the kobe pandemic has proved
to be extremely challenging
for the uk economy it's been a tough
year
headline gdp has declined by 9.9 in 2020
which is more than twice the fall that
happened in 2009
following the financial crash the
government has now borrowed
400 billion pounds dealing with a
pandemic
the government has stepped up to support
both the economy and local authorities
during the financial storm
the support was included providing over
seven billion pounds in extra funding to
local authorities
since the beginning of the pandemic and
ensuring that they in turn can support
the most vulnerable
in their communities this includes 4.6
billion pounds of on-ring fence grants
to cover additional costs which are
associated with a pandemic
in addition the government has provided
a further 1.1 billion pounds for social
care funding
and for a range of specific measures
such as the opening of high streets
safely
providing emergency support for rough
sleepers
preventing vulnerable families from
going hungry and developing tests and
trace services
the government has confirmed that local
authorities will receive a further 3
billion pounds
in extra grant funding during the
current year to support them meeting
their coronavirus pressures
the government is also providing funding
to support risk the risks of homeless
homelessness
during the cove 19 emergency through an
additional 254
million pounds of resource funding
including 103 million pounds
announced earlier this year for
accommodation and substance misuse
the government has increased funding for
local authorities by 2.2 billion pounds
next year
helping them continue to develop their
their services
their key services for all the residents
within their own area
councils across the uk will receive 51.2
billion pounds
in 2021 sorry 21 22
representing a 4.5 increase in cash
terms
to their core spending prowl this will
provide local councils
with the additional resources they need
to develop effective local services
and continue to support their
communities during the pandemic
the government is given a share of more
than 300 million pounds to develop tests
and tracing services
in their local communities over 300
million pounds will be provided to all
councils
in england to develop an action plans
to receive to reduce the spread of the
virus
such as the current outbreak on the
border of clifford ward
in our own borough the government is
also providing 170
million pounds to ensure vulnerable
households do not go hungry
councils will get a hunt an extra 170
million pounds
by the government's coded grant scheme
with at least 80 percent of this
earmarked to support
the hardest hit families with the cost
of food and bills this builds on the 63
million pounds
already provided to councils earlier to
help those struggling
the government is helping councils keep
those bills low meaning people will
keep more of their money while earning
continuing to earn
from their own their own jobs and their
own resources and to receive
local services the government will
provide 670 million pounds
next year to help councils reduce
council tax bills
for those least able to pay including
households impacted
impacted by the pandemic building on the
500 million pounds provided so far
during the pandemic in a key support
measure the government
has allowed councils to defer business
rate payments sorry business rate
payments
uh which will ease any immediate
financial pressures they face
councils have been allowed to defer 2.6
billion pounds
in business rate payments and the
government has been brought has brought
forward
care grant pope programs worth 815
million pounds
and these were already paid back back in
april to provide immediate support to
frontline
social care services and to ease
pressure on council finances
in trafford by mid 2021 the government
has provided the council with
177.67 million pounds worth of funding
this included 4.8 million pounds worth
of adult social care
funding uh infection control funding
and 43.74 million pounds worth
through this the small business grant
fund
and retail hospitality scheme
the budget before us tonight contains
many many measures which we actually
support
such as the additional funding for
children's and adult social care
additional investment to support
increases in the national living wage
investment in school buildings major
highways and other key infrastructure
improvements
leisure strategy and sports facilities
targeted support to some of the most
vulnerable residents
charging points for electric cars
improving green spaces
biodiversity public realm works in our
town centres
community safety improvements and town
centre and business loans
however there are aspects of the budget
that we do not agree with
starting with the proposed increase in
council tax
labour's budget will see the average
d-band property moving up to
720 pounds which includes 218 pounds
and 30 pence for the police and crime
commissioner
which is painful going towards paying
for a police force that the mayor has
overseen
being placed in special measures on his
watch
when i last developed delivered a
conservative budget back in
february 2018 the band d charge was
1 486 pounds which means that the
proposed charge tonight
is 11.5 more than that
i can only imagine that many residents
believe that they're not receiving
the service they are paying for
we've also seen some very questionable
spending decisions over last year the
council received 366 000 pounds
funding from the emergency active travel
fund to improve cycling
and walk-in options for residents
excuse me
the council recently admitted that as
part of the fund
it wrongly installed bollards on the
wrong side of lostok road in debut
as part of a forty six thousand pound
project that sort of failure will not
reassure residents
that their taxes are being well spent
it will come as no surprise to members
of the conservative group and also
oh uh sorry no no no
it will come as no surprise to members
that because of the conservative group
who have major reservations over the
council's investment strategy has
already been mentioned
by november 2020 the council leader
invested or made commitments to invest
up to 377
million pounds worth of borrowed money
much of which is in retail businesses
and are now likely to be worth
considerably less than the price paid
due to the current financial situation
the level of debt
has become concerning and it's likely to
rosa has
already given itself the ability to
increase that debt to 500 million pounds
through the investment strategy however
we cannot support the budget as it
currently stands i'd like to give notice
that we will be putting forward an
amendment will address some of the cuts
that otherwise would have been very
detrimental
to business in residence in trafford our
the amendment we will put forward
tonight has been
reviewed by the borough treasurer it
will retain
free transport to school for more
residents for more students
it will make our towns and village
centres more attractive to shoppers to
visit
it will maintain green spaces to a
better standard
it will now uh it will retain levels of
tree planting and i'm very grateful that
the council
have already agreed the the 80 000 pound
uh reversal on this this was one of our
uh one of our uh amendments that we're
going to put forward later on
mr mayor labour's budget is all about
tax hikes increased charges and cuts and
services
and in contrast the amendment that we
will propose will go some way to
encourage residents
in return to to shop and
visit our town centres to attain a
pleasant environment
and i commend it to the council thank
you mr mayor
thank you councillor myers and thank you
for giving notice of an amendment which
will be noted
at this stage um and now
call upon councillor newgrosh to respond
on behalf of the liberal democrats group
um mr mayor before i begin my connection
is extremely unstable i have actually
dropped out of this meeting already once
so
if that happens during this i do
apologize and that is why there is no
video
so 1992
was her majesty the queen's annas
horiblus
her horrible year the previous 12 months
can only be described locally
nationally and globally as a terrible
year
the loss of life the overwhelming
sadness of family and friends taken
many years before their time by this
time pandemic
over a hundred and twenty thousand loved
ones gone
residents and friends speak of
non-emptiness that can never be filled
a high death toll that unfortunately is
down solely to the uk government's
mishandling of this pandemic
resulting in comparatively one of the
worst death tolls in the developed world
i have been left deeply angry scathingly
so
at the appalling response or at times
lack of response
from the conservative government from
their initial inaction
to dodgy contracts with their chums for
undelivered or unusable ppe
to a 22 billion pound track and trace
system that was world beating
only in its price and another failure in
its implementation
the tory catalogue of failures have
prolonged this crisis
deepened its effects and greatly
increased the death toll
and economic devastation in addition to
the health effects of covid the uk has
suffered its worst economic contraction
in 300 years
greater than almost all industrial
nations on earth
world leading for all the wrong reasons
while i have little but condemnation for
national government
the opposite is true from our council's
response trafford council
proved it was agile resilient while our
staff has shown dedication
above and beyond i would like to
acknowledge thank and praise
all our staff that continue to work
often under extremely challenging
circumstances
to allow the flexibility this council
needed to continue providing vital
services
it would be cheerless of me not
at this point to acknowledge the role
played by our council leader
andrew weston from the very start andrew
offered
cross-party cooperation a unified
collaborative approach to fighting the
pandemic
the group leaders that speak tonight
have been given unprecedented weekly
access to data that track the council's
position
and response throughout this spending
this pandemic including
spending we were party too and had input
on
some very tough decisions some i can
tell you were deeply shocking to
consider
thankfully despite all that has happened
we've not faced our worst case scenarios
i'm especially proud that trafford took
early
extensive and continuing measures to
protect our most vulnerable residents
especially those in care although it
will take research in years to come to
know for certain
i feel sure that trafford's
collaborative cross-party flexible
response to pandemic
will have saved lives and benefited our
residents
i cannot cover the worst of the pandemic
without also
praising trafford's covid vaccination
plan
a plan and response that has been
implemented by a dedicated team of
officers from both the council and
health authority
the program has been a beacon of success
i'd like to take this opportunity to
offer our heartfelt
praise and thanks to all of those
involved
i must also make known our group's deep
gratitude respect and praise for the
thousands of local
residents and voluntary organizations
that have selflessly
stepped forward and to volunteer as part
of the local covert response
their community spirit was truly a joy
to behold
if a global pandemic was not enough for
us to contend with this year
we were also spectators to the countdown
for brexit negotiations
in the last minute brinkmanship a
christmas eve trade deal was announced
what has been the result of this the
haulier trade body reports that exports
from britain to the european union fell
by 68
in january amsterdam has just overtaken
london as europe's share
trading hub something described as
unthinkable by robert preston prior to
the brexit
these are huge losses of real income to
the uk
they will have a direct and detrimental
impact on both jobs
and government tax receipts now and in
years to come
a local business shared with me
instructions from their courier entitled
items not accepted for export to europe
it was a three-page list covering major
sectors of our economy
incredibly we can no longer even send
goods freely within the uk
the conservative and unions party of
great britain to give the tories their
full name
has succeeded in dividing our united
kingdom creating a border
in the irish sea a border enforced by uk
defra officers
they got it done but we will be left
counting the cost for years to come
the combined impact of covid and brexit
has had an awful toll on local business
regrettably some have failed in the last
year
many more of our residents are
furloughed facing an uncertain future
although we acknowledge the business
support the government has offered the
lib dems have long championed
the excluded group of nearly 3 million
people across the uk
that were not eligible for any support
at all
it is only in the last week that traffic
council has been able to expend
extend their discretionary grant scheme
to cover previously excluded residents
unfortunately not as generous as that
which has been already offered to other
groups
affected by the pandemic i do urge
anyone that
has yet to be able to complete claim
please visit our website and check if
they can
now with this terrible year as a
backdrop
national economic damage unseen for the
last 300 years
it's no surprise that this year's budget
has seen a series of extremely tough
choices we know that this year
we are relying on on reserves to the
tune of
11.4 million to make ends meet
whilst at the same time making deeply
regrettable cuts to services
in a normal year i'd be deeply critical
of both of these
but i failed to see how either could be
avoided this year
our reserves although worryingly low are
there for just such emergencies
it is right that we turn to them now in
the hope that we can
somehow rebuild them in years to come
despite the additional support local
government has seen
both in spending in the spending review
in november followed by the provisional
local government financial settlement in
december
which helped to mitigate some of the
losses attributed to covid
it is sadly clear that the amount is as
in previous years
simply not enough to make ends meet much
of the increases heralded from central
government
is directly attributable to council tax
increases
in a word they are saying that your
council tax payments
are part of their financial support to
trafford
because of this the 1.99 percent rise in
chelsea tax becomes unavoidable this
year
as it's already been costed in by the
conservative national government
i hope that trafford residents are
mindful of this when it comes time to
pay
our council tax i briefly also like to
mention the investment strategy
although the executive strongly
disagreed with my view on the additional
200 million debt agreed
by them at the last budget i do
acknowledge and thank them for their
cautious
low use of the extra allowable funds and
requests that they continue their
approach
in such uncertain times
we do express a concern to such deep
cuts
of approximately 2.2 million for child
social care
so soon after investing in early
intervention
early intervention investment is exactly
the right method to support vulnerable
young people
however we feel the ongoing lockdown
with the ongoing lockdown it may prevent
us gaining a clear
picture of need so cuts to this so
deeply so quickly
could well have an adverse impact on
children already in the system
to summarize not a single councillor
proposing or supporting this budget
tonight came into local politics to cut
services
not one we all came here at least i all
hope we all came here to do the best for
our residents
but this year has been an unprecedented
exceptional year
one ideally hope we never see the like
of again
we must fulfill our legal obligation to
approve a balanced budget
one that tonight is made all the much
harder by the last minute cut
announced by central government taking
an extra 1.15 million pounds from our
trafford road maintenance budget
that is 25 of its entire budget taken
hours before we debate the budget a
clear enough example if
any more were needed of central
government's contempt for local
governments finances
i thank you very much mr mayor
thank you councilman i now call upon
councillor coggins to respond on behalf
of the green
party thank you chair
we always start our budget speeches by
thanking the officers involved and we
have already thanked nikki and i think
to an extent graham tonight
and but this year i think we really need
to particularly acknowledge um what an
extremely difficult task they've
undertaken in the last 12 years
at 12 months uh the way our staff work
and the way the council
delivers its services has changed
radically this year i know that the
staff the finance staff who produced
this report have been working at the
kitchen table homeschooling as they go
and the finance teams who write the
budget have had to work on so many new
government grant schemes
often at short notice working long hours
giving up their weekends
so i think we really need to
particularly acknowledge the remarkable
effort of our council staff in finance
and elsewhere
as well as of course colleagues in the
nhs volunteers and others who've
contributed
so this year has been very different and
there are a number of measures that we
welcome in this budget
many of these measures are things that
we in the green party have called for in
the past and are now finally being
implemented
and there is a grant of 4.3 million
pounds in there for decarbonizing
council buildings which
is huge progress and we really really
welcome that
it's a step in the right direction
towards the savings of
13 per year that we need to make in
order to keep within our carbon budget
and the heat pumps solar pumps solar
panels and leds
that will be going into cancer buildings
and schools and elsewhere
and are really um badly needed
we also welcome moves to reduce damaging
light pollution and save taxpayer money
by changing the use of street lights
where it's safe to do so
and we're glad as altering them cancers
to see some clarification on the plans
for altering
town hall and and specifically that the
plans are to retain council ownership
and i think we can all agree that we
would like to see this beautiful
historic building put to better use
as green councils for ultraham will of
course be watching that very carefully
and there are changes that we welcome in
the way that the council manages its
green spaces again these are changes
that we've called for in the past
and we're pleased that cancer jerome's
motion on reducing
uh glyphosate uses fed into progress on
this hugely important issue as we face
the sixth
mass extinction of species and we rely
on our biodiversity to pollinate our
food crops and to give us clean air so
we really need to be making progress on
this and we're glad to see it in there
the measures described here are are some
steps in the right direction
it is important to note though and i
would like some reassurance on this
that in line with the guidance in the
good verge guide
we do need to put up signs and other
ways of of getting the message across to
residents
and about what we're doing on these and
these measures we know that
um creating you know wildlife havens and
and
beautiful habitats with wild flowers is
really appreciated by residents
we just need to make sure they're fully
informed along the way
the changes to subsidized parking are
also to be welcomed and i will discuss
that
later when we come to debate the
conservative budget amendment
and we also welcome the increase in
the council's reserves and this year has
seen increased
uncertainty and instability and at times
like this
we just need to have that little bit
extra um
to to fall back on it's important to
note that most of these measures
that were welcoming could actually have
been done one two
or even five years ago and the truth is
that these are measures that will save
money um and bring it or bring in income
and
they have been adopted later than they
needed to be perhaps slightly
reluctantly
and and one can't help wondering if
they're being adopted now not because of
a commitment to enhancing wildlife
habitats
improving our health or making our town
centers more attractive places to visit
but like so much else in our budget
because the finances dictate it
however whatever the reasons um
residents and businesses in trafford
will benefit and we're proud of the
green party's record of leading where
other parties follow
there are other changes that we couldn't
be described as welcoming but we
understand the rationale for
and agree with um and of course the
increase in council tax falls into this
category
this year we see an even bigger increase
than before
but of course our residents are in a
worse position financially than they
have ever been before
we've seen job losses on a massive scale
public sector pay freeze for our
overstretched council and nhs
staff and others but they have to find
the money now to pay a higher level of
council tax
the pay freeze we see in the budget
saves the council
millions as to a million as does the
changes to the living wage
but the real cost of these apparent
savings will be met
by our public sector staff and traffic
residents on low
wait low pay so we understand the
council's reasons for doing this
so in fact really what we're saying is
if this is a problem for national
government and national government has
let down local councils let down
our residents council tax is a
regressive measure
we would like to see the funding gaps
plugged by government using much
fairer taxes by forcing councils to
raise council tax in this way government
has made the less well-off people
in trafford pay more while the very
wealthy the large corporations and
crucially the big polluters
are not paying their pressure so we
would like to see a
radical system of carbon taxes to
rebalance our economy
around climate justice to pay for the
ambitious changes that we need over this
next decade
taxing polluters would bring rapid
behavior change and in the meantime
would give
a carbon dividend a pot of money that we
could use to fund a green new deal
to get us out of this recession
so there are the areas which we as i say
don't welcome but understand the reasons
for
um under areas of concern i've just
deleted the section on city of trees so
um thank you to the administration for
that last minute
change but i do also want to warn us
about
the airport yet again this year the
airport dividend has not paid out
and that has hit trafford's finances
heart and thanks to the
team at finances who have of course had
a a small contingency as they do for all
these things
but that isn't an ongoing solution we
know that we have to move to a world
where levels of flying aren't perhaps
not as low as they were in 2020
but certainly a lot lower than they were
in 2019
and traffic council really needs an
injection of climate realism
into our future thinking about the
airport we cannot continue our financial
reliance on the airport
we have to plan our future budgets
knowing the airport use
must decrease
in previous years the green group has
cited areas where we agree
but have ultimately voted against the
budget as a whole
this year as i've said is quite
different this year the choices facing
the council
have been stripped back not just by the
pandemic but by the fact that it comes
at the end of
10 to 11 years of austerity and we've
also seen as described that the council
is making some of the changes that we've
been calling for
for many years decarbonization of cancer
buildings
protecting and increasing our wildlife
habitats and just starting to question
the car dependence of our lifestyles
we take our role as constructive
opposition very seriously and mindlessly
voting against the budget
every year or indeed mindlessly voting
for the budget every year is not what we
came here to do
so given these small steps in the right
direction
combined with the particular stresses of
this unprecedented
year i've allowed myself one use of that
word tonight
we will be voting for the budget tonight
this doesn't mean that we are giving the
administration a clean bill of health
and it doesn't mean that we will be as i
say mindlessly voting in favor of all
future budgets
we still need to reduce our greenhouse
gas emissions by
13 every year we need to stop building
on our crucial green sites
and push for reduced airport use we need
to cancel the building of a new
unnecessary road about cross carrington
moths and stop
pouring hundreds and millions of our
pension contributions
into the world's biggest polluters the
fossil fuel giants
so what it does mean is that in
difficult and unusual times
we need to pull together and focus on
what we have in common
and i think we have done that very well
in trafford this year
thank you
[Music]
thank you councillor coggins i now
propose to deal with the amendments
councilman myers gave notice of an
amendment and i now ask that this be
moved please
without further comment
mr mayor um the council actually agrees
the
recommendations as given in the report
tonight subject to removing the
following
proposals first the introduction of
charges for home to school transport
which will cost
48 000 pounds the increase in parking
charges in our villages
64 000 pounds the introduction of higher
parking charges in town centers 136 000
pounds
uh to disallow free parking after three
o'clock at christmas time
which will cost fifty thousand pounds
the introduction of further diminished
street lights
and then delay when lights come on at
night and switch them off
before dawn seventy five thousand pounds
to stop routine checks on street lights
they're working 9 000 pounds reducing
the response time for engineers to
address problems such as 40 street
lights 82
000 pounds decreasing the grass cutting
to an interval
of 21 days at 67 000 pounds
to reduce the maintenance of green
spaces 36 000 pounds
to reduce the spraying of weeds to once
a year 20 000 pounds
and i'm very grateful that the labour
administrations agree to our
amendment number 11 which is to reduce
the contribution to the city of trees
program
which would have cost 80 000 pounds
the corporate director of finance and
systems has advised that these proposals
if adopted
would enable the council to set a legal
budget the total cost of the amendment
is now
600 637 000 pounds
and this would be funded through
application monies held in the budget
support reserve
thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor myers is the
motions the amendment seconded
it seconded mr mayor and i'll in the
interest of time i'll
i'll speak now if that's okay
that's three minutes please councillor
evans thank you
thank you mr mayor i'll save my thanks
and for
our offices and team to my summing up at
the end of this debate if i may
and regrettably through uh this labor
budget we're being asked to support
charging visitors
to our town and now village centers to
pay more to park or even
start to pay to pass when visiting our
businesses
and services we need to ask ourselves
whether the parking strategy is about
raising revenue
or is it to support the businesses and
town centres as a part of the ongoing
economic regeneration conservatives
believe that balance can be struck
between the two
now is not the time to be raising
charges when our high streets are on
their knees
following the impact of the past 12
months when we can see a route out of
this pricing
crisis affecting us all why are we
saying to our local businesses
that we we will be making it less
attractive for residents
to visit them indeed one resident who
responded to the consultation on car
parking
wrote i live in timperley and regularly
use
the free car park to access local shops
if i am charged to park in temple i will
instead drive to tesco in bagley
where i can get everything i would
purchase in simply
under one roof with free parking
this will drive local people away from
using the village to shop
and template businesses may not survive
that's one resident
i think it sums up very clearly the risk
to our town and village centres
through what labour are proposing these
tiny adjustments that make all the
difference
and drive custom away i quote from the
detail regarding your parking proposals
labor will have a proactive approach to
enforcement
our town centres don't need a proactive
approach to enforcement
they need a sympathetic approach the 50
piece will kill our town
but the 50 pounds will bury them
priority three of trafford's current
corporate plan is that trafford
has successful and thriving town centres
and
communities if this is a serious
ambition of this regime
then supporting the conservative
amendment will go some way
to demonstrating to local businesses
that we are serious about supporting
them
through these difficult times members
please
support our amendment it's well costed
it will benefit our residents across the
borough thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor evans um i've got a
point of order from councillor weston
councillor western
thank you mr mayor i'm seeking to
understand
a little further from the um section 151
office uh be it nikki or graham whoever
is appropriate
on the robustness or otherwise of this
amendment in particular i'm keen to
understand
um whether they feel that it would be
prudent to press ahead
with this um as it's certainly a
significant
unfunded amendment in terms of it being
a revenue pressure funded for one year
by capital
um so that's a point of order um seeking
clarification from the 151 officer
please
i think just to respond to that i think
in terms of the amendment
um these two issues that i've i've
considered i think
one is to look at the impact of the on
the budget in the
um for 2021-22
and would it actually materially affect
the overall robustness and legality of
that budget
are you setting a balanced budget and
maintaining
minimum level of reserves and i think it
wouldn't materially impact on that
i think a section one officer what i've
got to be really concerned about though
is it's obviously the sustainability of
budgets in future years
and i think what what the amendment
would do in terms of using more reserves
to replace with current savings
will have the impact of increasing the
budget gap in 2223 from 11.1 million to
11.7
million which i don't think is
appropriate obviously as it will
place further additional sustainability
um
concerns on the budget in future years
and i think
just in terms of the issue of prudency i
think
just summing up on that i think in my
professional opinion i would therefore
say it's not prudent
thank you mr bentley i'm going to invite
the other members who have indicated to
speak
um councillor carter you'd like to
comment on the amendment
i would thank you mr mayor and i'm
obviously going to talk about the home
school transport
and i appreciate council myers we've
been through this before but we're going
to do it again
our administration will not have a
policy that continues to benefit one
group of children above others
the current policy favors children
who've passed for grammar school
in a way that children who've not
qualified for grammar school are not
offered the same financial protection
families on the lowest incomes will
continue to be protected
but we cannot afford to pay for parents
who can afford to pay for themselves
trafford grammar schools are rightly
valued by parents
and we know that children from over 30
local authorities sit the test
it is not acceptable for us as a council
to fund travel to children
who could attend a more local school but
choose
to attend a grammar school that is
further away
unless they are on a low income the
majority of families that this current
policy benefits live
in wa14 and 15 postcodes
and these families have access to both
wellington school
and ultraman college of arts both
excellent schools
if however they choose to go to sales
stratford or ernst and grammar
that is parental choice and the council
should not be made to pay for this
many families where children have not
qualified for a grammar school place
also have the same right and might
consider that their child
would be best served by attending a
school further away
such as a faith school a single sex
school or a school that they perceive
might provide better outcomes however
these families do not have the option to
apply for travel assistance
because the discretionary criteria is
not extended to them
consequently they fund this choice
themselves
as an example the october 2020 census
shows that 1041 traffic children
who do not live in altering them attend
blessed thomas halford catholic college
42 receive travel assistance under the
low income criteria
which will continue but not one of the
remaining
999 receive travel assistance
even though they live more than three
miles from the school
parents are choosing to pay for
transport to get their children into an
excellent catholic high school
we undertook two consultations on this
one was the general budget consultation
and the other one was specific to
parents
who either benefit or may benefit from
the current policy in the future
the results clearly demonstrate that 65
of respondents are either in favor or
strongly in favor of changing the policy
obviously there will be some families
who are affected who are currently in
receipt of travel assistance
and so we will open an appeal system to
work with these families who contact us
to seek a solution to their financial
difficulties
however i do not believe a change in
policy will stop
one family from applying for a place in
a grammar school
because of the cost of a bus fare the
prime minister
came to power with the message that he
wanted to level up the country
what you are advocating is the precise
opposite
you want to preserve the privilege for
those who can already afford it
we are taking this stance so that the
council stretched resources can be
targeted
where they are most needed and where
they will have the most impact on
securing the best outcomes for children
it is not so much a cost-saving exercise
as a moral duty
to treat all of trafford's children the
same thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor carter i'm going to
bring in councillor evans just to to
reply
um he's asked very politely to come back
in councillor evans
appreciate amsterdam thank you very much
um it's interesting the word appropriate
from mr bentley when referring to this
amendment and i wouldn't normally have
such great respect for graeme
and so appropriate i consider
specifically at this time
and the our group considers and our
members should consider
all these items are appropriate they
support our residents directly in
appearance
in our town centers everywhere is it
appropriate to be attempting to boost
our
general reserves while penalizing our
hard-pressed
town centers i think not and a 637
thousand pounds is appropriate at this
time
thank you thank you councillor evans
councillor thomas please
[Music]
council thomas are you on mute
sorry mr mayor can you hear me now yes
thank you thank you
the first thing i noticed in reading the
amendment was the lack of any mention
of the cost of coronaviruses although
council of io's party political
broadcast was enlightening
i would like to remind him that mr
rashford is actually the catalyst behind
feeding poverty-stricken children uh and
vulnerable children
at this time there's no mention of the
difficulties faced over the last 12
months on council finances
or any disasters dissatisfaction of the
government's failure
to set up set up and step up for local
councils
as per robert uh generic's 16th of march
2020 statement saying that this
government will do
whatever it takes the budget
motion has required monumental work by
council ross and the finances
team and the difficulties faced stem
from the shortfall faced by
the lack of replacement of funds and
costs created
by the covid pandemic despite the
promises made
at the outset and more recently the
commission of the conservative group's
support
in lobbying central government to ease
budget pressures
in 2018 this conservative group tabled
an amendment
uh to the budget that may have led to an
illegal budget being set
um if it had been carried in 2019's
amendment
that was challenged as being far from
robust enough by the corporate finance
team
and we just heard from the s151 officer
that is now herald his has not been
prudent enough and not
taking into account coming obstacle
calls in future budgets
into any form of account whatsoever that
is why i cannot support this
amendment thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor thomas now we're
running late into the meeting now can i
remind everybody that we are speaking to
the amendment
and i'm now proposing that we have two
minutes for our speeches just two
minutes
and then can i just say again we are
talking about the amendment thank you
i'm going to go to councillor jerome
councillor jerome
thank you thank you chair um our climate
emergency
our glass freak glass fake free trafford
our trees and verges motioned by this
green group we're all unanimously
supported by this council
this conservative amendment runs against
all these motions
the budget proposes cutting costs that
will improve biodiversity by allowing
verges to grow
and flower it proposes cutting our hard
surface weed spraying by half
meaning we will be 35 away from being
glyphosate free from where we were in
2019
this amendment proposes to stop these
positive changes that will make our
borough greener
the tories also seem to connect economic
success in our town centres
with free and cheap to motor vehicles
this is this is a false premise where
town centres and high streets have been
opened themselves to active travel these
have been a proven boost to our local
economy
we need to move away from car dependency
and encouraging people away from driving
into our towns
this amendment is andy antigreen and i
for one will not be supporting it
thank you matt
thank you councillor thank you
councillor jerome can we have councillor
right
please thank you mr mayor as other
members on this
on this side of the chamber have already
stated i cannot vote for this amendment
this evening
the self-proclaimed party of fiscal
responsibility have now for two years in
a row
proposed raiding the reserves a former
leader of the conservatives once stated
there isn't a magic monetary
well it seems in opposition there
clearly is the savings in this budget
are only being implemented because the
conservative government
with some help early on from the liberal
democrats have for 11 years now
destroyed council budgets
rather than putting the economic
security of this council at risk
by suggesting raiding our reserves maybe
you could stand up to your government
in westminster and ask that they
properly fund local authorities
in relation to the proposed removal of
the increase in parking charges
even with the increase trafford remains
60
cheaper than stockport 30p cheaper than
salford
and 70p cheaper than wigan to park for
two hours in our town centres
however let's not forget the myth that
providing cheap or even free parking
leads to economic success as councillor
jerome has just pointed out
it doesn't quite the contrary making
town centres safer
cleaner and greener is proven to improve
football
and increase spend combining the
increase in charges with investment in
better public realm
and much improved cycling and walking
facilities will enhan
enhance our town centres encouraging
active travel and moving away from our
alliance on the car
particularly in already congested town
centres is the right thing to do
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
wright
councillor morgan please
christopher um could you expect that
quickly um
i can't believe we're actually debating
dimming our street lights
um just to save 75 000 pounds uh not
significantly less than that's what
we've wasted on
um bollards on lost hot road um well i'm
allowed to knock on doors which haven't
been for a long time residents have
never complained to me
um that street lights are too bright but
many many many times residents have
complained to me about the street lights
not being good enough
and let's look at if we don't pass this
amendment what the result is
a greater risk of social and social
behavior and a greater risk from crime
more people choosing to drive than um
walk at night
and more risk on our roads the aaa
estimated in 2017 that 11 people have
been killed due to
street lights being dimmed since 2009
and let's also dismiss the argument this
is um to reduce carbon emissions
that's a smokescreen this is just simply
trying to reduce costs
um we're also concerned about the
expectation that uh residents will
um need to report faulty um streetlights
the council rather council proactively
um expecting those faults
that will mean longer wait more time and
particularly in areas like trafford park
even even longer do we want as a council
to be increasing residence anxiety when
they walk on our streets
the worry in my area um of trafford is
really really apparent from crime at the
moment
and the neighborhood watch um have
really really stated that
the perception that this would have on
the impact of um crime
because it but also because it does not
give the reassurance to residents and it
means a fear of crime
um i would urge the council to um help
retain our
residents confidence to walk on our
streets at night and
support the conservative amendment this
evening thank you
thank you councillor morgan councillor
taylor
thank you mr mayor i'd like to thank
councillor ross nicki bishop and graham
bentley and all the officers of the
financial
uh team for producing this prudent and
carefully considered budget
to achieve this at any time is very
significant
but in the face of the challenges of a
global pandemic it is nothing short of
incredible
and they should be commended for this
i'm disappointed
but not surprised that the conservative
party have submitted an amendment
i consider it to be uncollegiate
unnecessary and ill-judged
it's it what it is is an outrageous
attempt at political point scoring
from trafford tories made even more
appalling
in light of the tory government's
catastrophic handling of the coronavirus
crisis
preceded by a decade of asset stripping
vicious cuts it is an insult both to the
people of trafford
and to the professional judgment of our
directors of corporate directors of
finances
and i and the labor group will not be
supporting it
thank you mr man excuse me
thank you thank you councillor taylor
councillor boys
thank you mr mayor um i'd like to make
reference to three particular elements
of the budget each of which involves
flora first the idea that wild flowering
some of our green areas will reduce
maintenance compared with grass cutting
is i would suggest
a false premise if one refers to the
website of the royal horticultural
society
one reads that wildflower areas require
an annual maintenance program
involving mowing at specific times
coupled with judicious weed control
control of the particularly unwelcome
perennial weeds has to be carried out
before seed sets
and by hand since weaker suitable for
use on grass
will kill the wildflowers being
encouraged with such a program not to be
properly implemented
the areas rapidly become weedstrone
wildernesses
hence there's no savings here second the
concept of reducing the frequency of
grass cutting to every 21 days
my copy of dawson's practical lawn craft
suggests that the degree of frequency of
cut must in practice
be largely governed by the amount of
growth which in turn is related to the
weather conditions
season of the year and fertility of the
soil furthermore the frequency of cut
must also take into account the desired
height of cut depending on the activity
which is to take place
sport england publish recommendations
for use for football rugby cricket etc
and for safety reasons these should be
the guide to our cutting regime
not some arbitrary frequency which under
some circumstances may prove wasteful
and more likely given the changing
climate of warmer and wetter weather
which produces faster growth and for a
longer period may actually become
potentially dangerous to users of our
green spaces
third and finally the reduction of weed
spraying to once a year
as far as our footpaths and gutters are
concerned weeds fall into two main
categories
deep-rooted weeds such as dandelions and
docks whose control demands the removal
of the tap root
and without using glycophage this often
requires mechanical removal
more shallow rooted weeds can be
controlled
thank you
thank you um councillor ross please
thank you mr mayor um as with others i'm
recommending that we do not support this
amendment this evening it is at best
reckless at worst dangerous with the
financial situation
you'll note from what i said before that
we have taken very careful approach to
our reserves this year and
applied a prudent amount to bridge the
budget gap
this amendment seeks to take another 600
000
from the reserves which as our section
151 officer has just stated
would mean putting gaps in the future on
our
on our budget gaps in the scrutiny
committee report that we considered as
an executive
um as part of the process the report
expressed concerns in relation to the
level of required reserves held by the
council
including concerns about the size and
use of the budget support reserve next
year
again this would fly in the face face of
the concern that was raised by scrutiny
committee councillors as part of this
budget process
i don't need to say again we're in a
time of economic uncertainty and that
will have a direct impact on our
medium-term financial outlook
including our collection of business
rates and council tax
it would be reckless to commit any more
from the reserves at a time that we're
likely to require flexibility to meet
the challenges of the year ahead
i'm also concerned to hear about some
comments made about council tax
increases and the invest asset
investment strategy
it seems from this the conservatives
have said that they're opposed to our
council tax increase
despite them raising it in 2017 by 4.99
and in 2018 by 4.99
this would take a further 5 million
pounds from our revenue budget
and a further 7.61 million pounds would
go as part of their
opposition to the asset investment
strategy
there is no sense to these proposals
and i would ask council to reject them
completely and support our budget
as as it stands thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor ross councillor
welton please
uh thank you mr mayor i i find this
amendment
just quite reassuring actually because
after the
green washer measurements the tories
have proposed for the last two
years the mask has slipped they've
turned tail
and what we've got is pro air pollution
pro-light pollution
and pro-pesticide suggestions and they
want to raid the reserves
to do it so you know this is obviously
what they really think
and sometimes i wonder if trafford
tourists have a clue
what their national transport policies
are because virtually everything they do
and they
and say publicly contradicts them
only this week a report for the for the
department of transport said increasing
parking charges
when allied with improvements to walking
and cycling facilities
can create a sustained shift in behavior
towards
greener travel um i think that sounds
like a very positive thing i'm
happy to praise the national government
for it and
unfortunately the traffic tories aren't
don't seem to be interested in this at
all
and therefore i have to reject this
amendment thank you
thank you councillor weltson um
councillor holden please
thank you mr mayor i'd like to address
very briefly the home homeschool
transport issue
this proposal will save 48
000 pounds that's barely enough for 200
yards of unused cycle track it's quite
clear that the proposal wasn't about
saving money we've heard that
from the contribution that council
carter made
this is about political manipulation and
to
build into a saving of 48 000
additional administrative costs for
appeals
and for the determination of who gets
the money and who doesn't
is crazy but it does
damage the parents who want their
children
to go to grammar school who
dare to want their children to get
the best education for which they're
capable
it's interesting to note that this point
has been highlighted by
residents throughout the council
consultations
who want their children to go to the
grammar schools in altringham or the
single sex
grammar schools in austria and i'd urge
other members here tonight to support
parental choice
and support the conservative amendment
the honest
conservative amendment to support our
grammar schools and not try to put them
out of business
by stealth and small
narrow cuts over a period of years thank
you mr man
thank you councillor holden councillor
coggins please
thank you chair and the green party
group will not be supporting the
amendment tonight
and i need to say a little more than
that the s151 officer has just described
it as not prudent
we cannot go around covering everyday
expenses
out of our reserves that's just pushing
our financial problems on to next year
however i do want to take issue with
some of the policy decisions
too um briefly on the issue of
subsidized parking we have to remember
people there is no such thing as free
parking
when we don't charge the full cost for
the use of public space we are
subsidizing
the owners of private cars we are apart
from blue badge holders
we are making uh the the less well-off
in our in our
area pay for the the advantages given to
those who are better off
but also i'm really disappointed by
cancer evidence's argument and the idea
that we should be making policy based on
anecdotal
evidence from one resident and you know
we really need to be well informed in
these decisions we need to listen to the
evidence
the evidence is that residents keep
telling us they want safer camera
cleaner streets we know the towns and
cities across the world that have moved
to having more walking and cycling
more people friendly towns have seen a
huge increase in how their businesses
are thriving
so i'm really disappointed with that um
from cancer evans
and finally on number six and seven in
the amendment i do have some sympathy
we would like to be able to keep the
street light
checking that we have the system we
would like to keep the
um response time for engineers
addressing problems as we have
but again the conservatives have to
consider why we can't afford this
it's because we've had years of being
the lowest council tax authority in
greater manchester
and because of cuts from national
government and
so this this amendment is misguided
uninformed and financially irresponsible
and the green party group will be voting
against it
[Music]
thank you councillor coggins councillor
anste
thank you very much mr mayor can i um
just point out to members who are
choosing to paint
uh this amendment as fiscally
irresponsible because of the use of
application of reserves
that the substantive budget is based on
10.8 million pounds application
of reserves and so it is a relatively
small amount of money that chooses to
give something back to the residents and
businesses
and of the brewer and so you cannot have
it both ways you cannot criticize
fiscal improvements for 600 000 pounds
and then
wholeheartedly support a budget that
uses over 10 million pounds
of reserves and if that's not kicking a
can down the road to next year
i really don't know what is and so so
just point that out to
to members who are criticizing and
seeking to paint this as irresponsible
what it is is very responsible to
support businesses to support town
centres to support our residents
in the midst of a pandemic before we
even think about economic recovery
and if you want to take a decision again
next year then that's fine but this is a
this is a decision
for now that gives something back to our
residents and businesses
and is totally uh and as green bentley
has rightly pointed out immaterial in
the grand scheme of things to be able to
set
a budget this year that would do
something that would show that this
council
is thinking about economic recovery and
i think uh
for those reasons and for the reasons
that uh
you know i i i find it incredible uh
that the
the application of reserves if it's a
labour party or green party policy is
fine
if it's a if it's a conservative
amendment it's not they're double
standards and our residents shouldn't
have support with that thank you very
much customer
thank you councillor anste councillor
new grush
you mr mayor um i have to speak on one
point of this so most of this
uh amendment i i cannot support but
there's one thing and
i would be remiss without saying that my
residence of timply village
clearly uh spoke about the parking
nightmare they've had
for the last year and a half ever since
the
um health center the sorry library has
been turned into a library and health
center with
some building in the middle of their car
park this has led to them
to uh have street parking
curb parking and they were all looking
forward to the fact that
maybe when the finally a a car park is
restored to them
that there would be some sort of free
parking and i know
subsidized parking for residents
and for visitors just to remove the
problem they have been blighted by
by nearly two years it would be remiss
of me not to say that that has been an
issue
and i fully support that we look to
mitigate
for the one village that i do know about
um i can't speak for other villages
so dad thank you very much for that
thank you councillor new gross
councillor acton
counselor are you on mute hello
hello can you hear me now
we can hear you now counselor
hi yeah if the tories
really cared about the council budget
and really want to restore the services
that they mention in their amendment
and i think that we beg
the question really that they never
supported
any lobbying their government to restore
the savage cuts and they were savage and
are savage
and the funding they have taken away
from local government
and this council for the last 11 years
and not to fully fund what the
government promised during the pandemic
so to me you know
what i would like to have seen is some
recognition around the cuts
and the desperate financial situation
that all councils are going through and
this one
is no different to the many councils
right across the country
and i think we've heard from the 106
officer and for me i i do believe
that we should reject uh this tory
proposal the amendment okay
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
acton councillor blackburn you'd like to
contribute
uh thank you thank you mr mayor for
letting me speak
um i wanted to mention a priority for
residents within the borough
and that is the refuse collections i
suspect all of us in this chamber
have been contacted by residents at some
point
complaining that one of the bins has not
been collected on time
so residents are often unsure if they
can leave their bins out
again overnight the council is telling
residents
to expect the bin to be emptied at some
point over the next
48 hours surely the solution here
is better management both operationally
and financially
to ensure that bins are empty the first
time round
we saw the chaos that labour's badly
managed changes to bin collection rounds
in 2019 brought about and we don't want
rotting rubbish left in our bins in our
streets any longer
than it has to be residents have also
wondered
whether the council have already made
savings by not
undertaking many assisted bin
collections for the elderly
or disabled residents want efficient
refuse collections that they pay for
within their council tax
which yet again will rise under this
labour-run council and i would urge
other
sensible members to support the
conservative amendment
thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor blackburn now i'm
advised that councillor ross has
a right to reply to the amendment
councillor ross do you
wish to reply to the amendment i don't
think there's anything more to say than
it's reckless please vote against it
thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor ross we'll now move
to the vote
and i should not put the member to the
vote and you have a screen in front of
you
please vote
uh
is that it yeah
okay the amendment is lost everybody the
amendment
the amendment is lost we'll now go back
to
um
to speak to the main motion and i've got
just two speakers at the moment for that
and begin with councillor rad said
you're going to speak to the main motion
and we have two minutes thank you uh mr
merkel
hopefully you can see me now yeah i'm
delighted supporting this budget
with around 170 million pound investment
in the capital program
i'd like to highlight just a few of
those areas i'm really pleased
and welcome the investment in a new
chapel and wrestlemania
cremators helping provide a much needed
and improved facilities those attending
services along with a more
environmentally friendly form a funeral
service
which will help support any
carbonization strategy on top of that
i'd also like to highlight ms challenge
fund work with around 35 million
investment over the next few years
helping to support our walking and
cycling strategy
encouraging people to stay healthier
with ernst and sales to sail more areas
particularly benefiting from large
investments from that fund
and mr mayor despite a last-minute cut
by government of over a million pounds
we are still investing many millions of
pounds
to support the overall highway network
helping to make all of our
infrastructure infrastructure even
safer for everyone further and in
addition we're proposing a further
50 000 pound investment in the highway
tree program
we also recently approved going out to
attendance part of our ebv
ev strategy investing over 400 000
electric vehicle charging facilities
which will actually help encourage
that to take off electric vehicles and
further support the carbonization of
transport
however mr michael not finish with a
quick comment on the conservative
amendment
which was clearly a misinterpretation of
of the proposals which is clearly
being looked at now from an
environmental perspective
we have eradicated the use of weed spain
if they did not aware this
completely in part from green spaces and
and was taking the step further out to
the hard areas now
and i believe as has been said both
people this is a positive step forward
our leaders already highlighted issues
around the city of trees network is
continuing
bringing investments of hundreds of
thousand pounds like in the mersey
valley
and indeed they involve children in
planting and one last point mr mayor
likewise the reduction in grass-cutting
regimes and the introduction of
more wildflower meadow areas is actually
to help
insect population such work though will
only be carried out
where it's safe to do so yes some things
may look a little different
however i would not want this being
misinterpreted
so i trust this sets the record straight
as to why this work is happening
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
said council councillor patel
thank you mr mayor this is my second
budget as a member of the executive
and on top of the response to covid
officers and my exec colleagues have
worked hard for many months to present
this budget position
thank you to all involved i didn't
become a councillor to make cuts or
raise council tax
it's been a rather painful and difficult
process nevertheless
difficult decisions need to be made and
i am proud that we continue to protect
the most vulnerable and invest in the
things that matter to the people of
trafford
i'm happy to commend this budget to
council against a hugely challenging
backdrop we have lots of positives in
our capital programme
that seek to enhance our open spaces and
provide opportunities for sport and
physical activity in the borough
over the last 12 months our borough's
parks have played a vital role in
keeping
people active providing safe accessible
spaces for residents in very challenging
times
they've never been so well used or
needed we are committed to our open
spaces and i'm pleased that we're able
to continue our investment into play
areas and park infrastructure
through our capital programme i would
like to thank one trafford staff for
their ongoing work in our parks
whilst many of us can work from home
crews have been out on the ground
throughout this public health emergency
with the support of the football
foundation i'm delighted we're investing
in the borough's football facilities
supporting grassroots football in
trafford and following on from the
january exec where our new leisure
strategy was approved
this budget provides the business
foundations for future refurbishments of
sales stretford and ultron leisure
centers
developing the first sustainable plan
for our leisure centres in many years
critically this budget identifies
funding for essential improvement and
maintenance works in our leisure centers
tackling some of the backlog of repairs
i'm not just a council who makes
decisions from
above my family use of borrowers parks
leisure centres and open spaces
no one can fail to notice a decline in
the resilience of our built environment
and facilities
a slow creep over the last 10 years if
we are to truly value our open spaces
and recognize the importance of physical
activity
then the financial support to sustain
and renew has to come from the top
buildback beta would see fair funding
for local councils from central
government for parks and leisure
facilities
it's frustrating that for the second
year in a row the opposition's response
to these difficult decisions
is to suggest that we blow the council's
reserves instead of facing up to the
realities of the crisis in local
government funding
i'm wondering where we would have been
this year had we have taken their advice
at the last budget
to blow the reserves i wonder where
we'll be next year when we're faced
again with a huge funding gap
and the year after that it's a magic
wand fingers in the ears stuff from the
opposition
diversion tactics from the real issue of
central government under funding thank
you mr mayor
ask everybody to um limit their remarks
to one minute now please everybody just
one minute councillor freeman please
thank you mr mayor uh the budget setting
has been extremely challenging
when you consider the uk economy has
shrunk by nearly 10 percent in the last
12 months
that the claimant count in trafford has
risen by a staggering
117 percent in the last 12 months the
highest
any gm borough and i think
this budget mr mayor anyone who believes
that the effects of the pandemic are
minimal
lives in a different world and anyone
who doubts our resolve through this
budget to do
before you to our level best for our
residents and businesses
throughout traffic to help them recover
is similarly deluded
like many of this chamber i'm very angry
at the government and the continued
failure to fund trafford and other las
the promise of whatever it takes despite
the earlier you you eulogy of the
government by council myers
or should i say his conservative party
broadcast has proven
to to be hollow words um
and the the burden of the cost of this
pandemic is being put fairly and
squarely
on the shoulders of the council
taxpayers finally i want to pay tribute
to our hard-working staff
uh the people who put the budget
together and again i'd say to me we must
never forget our staff of our most
valuable asset that is something else
this central
government failed to realize by enacting
the public sector pay freeze
they forget it is the councils like ours
and our staff
who i'm very proud of delivering the
pandemic response for them on the front
line
i commend the budget to this council
thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor freeman ask again
everybody to to limit your comments to
one minute councillor hartley please
thank you mr mayor we we do have some
tour members tonight with very
short memories blaming covid for the
crisis that we see in local government
funding
when since 2010 conservative governments
have cut local government funding
by 29 the result of deliberate policy
choices
not the recent pandemic the disdain with
which the tories have treated local
councils
is all too clear rather than picking
holes in a most challenging budget moved
by councillor ross the tourists could do
a lot more for trafford residents
by bringing some pressure to bear on
their friends in westminster
to come up with a long-term funding
settlement for local government
and for social care that allows
frontline services which the public have
so desperately needed over the last 12
months
to be properly and sustainably funded
for local government all residents have
seen from the tories is a series of
broken promises
and come the local elections in may
trafford residents will still face very
challenging circumstances
but they will also face a simple choice
a compassionate council
led by labour or the chaos that we've
seen tonight from conservative members
with councillor myers and with
councillor evans thank you
thank you thank you for your patience uh
councillor dr barclay please
thank you mr mayor yes financial
circumstances are
challenging but some of labour's cost
cutting proposals are damaging
i especially have concerns over reducing
the care of roadside verges in
residential areas
the intention is to create environments
for wildlife in residential areas
there's little evidence that this
happens
by the summer months we're more likely
to see unruly and ugly ugly overgrowth
running along our pavements
this has a negative impact on visual
immunity and then feeling that
localities are being run down and
neglected
and we know that long grass and wild
growth provides in sanitary conditions
for dogs excrement to hide and we know
that that's really unsafe for children
and pets alike
one of the consequences of this pandemic
has been that we need to
be able to appreciate our local area to
enjoy our local walks around it
it's so important therefore that we do
maintain our residential verges
after all the impact of the neglect is
virtually on people's doorsteps
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
dr barclay
councillor wright please thank you mr
mayor i just wanted to concentrate on
the positive
positives of this year's budget and
perhaps reflect on the achievements made
by this administration
and our wonderful council staff this
year within my portfolio
40 million pounds worth of affordable
housing offered through development
the stratford and civic quarter area
action plans progressed
the first social housing to be built in
a decade ready this
april new a bed every night
accommodation in old trafford to re-home
rough sleepers
successful future high streets fund
application worth 17 million pounds for
stratford
proving our commitments watering them by
progressing plans for the stanford
quarter and the grafton centre
working hard to deliver place plans for
hail and sale more
working hard to find funding to deliver
the improved town centre and public
realm that sail deserves
begin working on master plans for old
trafford warside and trafford park
there are just a few of the achievements
we have made and will go on to make in
the next financial year
it's an incredible achievement by our
staff who have done this despite
significant time and financial pressures
right you've gone past your minute i'm
afraid i really have to quickly show
apologies for that thank you councillor
jerome please
thank you man
there are plenty of things to be
positive about in this this budget
the uh generation of strategic locations
including altringham town centre um also
um public realm improvements in altering
them which will amount to over 2 million
pounds
there'll also be development of the
leisure center which is welcome
and also um 88 000 pounds of uh
maintenance for
october town hall but one of the things
i was most excited about
is the resurfacing and reconstruction
plans for some of ultringham's roads
we've worked really hard with residents
to during that november period to get
the consultation in from councillors
to make sure our roads were considered
stoker avenue
oldfield road the downs moss lane
and just to mention a few but to hear
that government funding of 1.5 million
is now being cut to this budget is uh
quite shocking and
indeed and it will certainly be hard
going back to residents to explain that
thank you mayor
thank you councillor jerome uh
councillor slater please
thank you mr mayor and from a health
fulfilling inequalities
perspective it is it's a positive budget
that we are actually setting
today is balanced i'd like to thank
councillor ross and officers for all the
hard work that they wanted
on making it in these very difficult
times against a backdrop of 10 years of
public sector court
the council has undertaken the very
important equality impact assessment
and duty to our residents i'm extremely
pleased that we've had no compulsory
redundancies
and and and and and any changes staffing
have been through a voluntary
um process and also i'm really pleased
that we have to tax
on hard term hard at hard work long
terms and condemn
employment as they have been in previous
years
council staff set up as uh as the public
sector always does during this pandemic
and the government be funding councils
properly not putting further financial
strains on councils
this play on the importance of public
health and it needs to be
funded adequately some ccg
have shown the importance of locality
working and have worked hard to keep
traffic safe during these unprecedented
times
i'd like to just setting this legal
budget
and i hope everybody can support it this
evening thank you
thank you councillor slater um can we
have councillor hines please
thank you mr mayor um like so many
authorities trafford is planning for a
surge in the demand for children
services as a result of the pandemic and
we're investing a million pounds to
support that
um surge in demand and i'm very proud of
the progress that we're making
we're also investing in targeted support
and to wrap that support around children
and families
and when they most need it but whilst
we're preparing for a further surge in
demand the governments are sadly burying
their heads in the sand
about the crisis that is building for so
many children
the outgoing children's commissioner has
said today that children
are largely invisible to governments and
it is the most vulnerable who are at
risk of slipping through the net
this is not good enough the pandemic is
not impacting everyone in the same way
but is exacerbating the pre-existing gap
between children
leading to a potentially devastating
impact on the life chances of vulnerable
young people
i'm proud of the poverty strategy we've
brought forward in trafford
but it's so important that government
puts funding and substance behind their
talk of leveling up
we know the mental health of many
children and young people has been
affected by the pandemic but again
this has been largely ignored by
government the government must answer
those unanswered questions ask you to
wind up there thank you
thank you um
councillor carr please you have one
minute thank you
thank you mr mayor i'd like to add my
thanks to the executive and council
officers who have done
an incredible job delivering a budget
that safely addresses
a cavernous funding deficit relating to
covid and a shocking lack of support
from central government
i'd particularly like to highlight some
of the measures that will help to
safeguard health and well-being
in the wake of covid these include the
living well in my community
and living well at home initiatives as
well as advancing the short stay in
hospital programmes
that will help maintain independence and
reduce reliance on adult social care
with its associated costs
finally reviewing the leisure offer to
be more proactive
in protecting physical health and mental
health and well-being is absolutely
crucial
as well as all the measures that
encourage cycling and walking
and protect our green spaces thank you
thank you councillor carr councillor
harding please
thank you mr mayor uh a minute will not
give me long enough to do justice to the
incredibly hard work that we've done
across social care in trafford a huge
thank you
to the dedicated and professional
leadership of diane eaton and her team
i don't think any of us in this chamber
can ever truly imagine
the adversity and challenges that our
providers
have faced and our team have faced
across social care
they do not stop at weekends evenings
and christmas
seven days a week 24 hours a day 365
days
a year but just to echo some of the
comments of councillor patel
i didn't come into local government to
make people's lives
worse i came in to make things better
and i'm proud of the unison ethical care
charter
that we have brought forward in trafford
we have much to do
but as councillor carr has just
referenced for living well at home
bringing people closer to home all of
those things but i'm really interested
in colleagues across the chambers
comments counselor and today references
kicking the cam
that's exactly what this government is
doing with social care
when boris johnson stood up as prime
minister to say he was fixing clothing
thank you councillor walsh thank you
appreciate you
appreciate your patience everybody this
evening um
we're now going to ask uh the leaders to
wind up councillor coggins
will have five minutes has been as as
was agreed earlier
councillor coggins you have five minutes
to wind up um the debate
from your group thank you thank you
share
um i want to pick up on a few issues
we've heard tonight
and i want to clarify some of my
comments on the conservative amendment
i know cancer and stay claimed that
large amounts of the substantive budget
were
also based on using reserves for
day-to-day savings
however i had actually unpicked that
question myself
with the um the section 151 officers
over the last few days
and in fact what's going on is that
there is a difference of principle
elsewhere in the budget reserves have
been used to cover day-to-day
impacts where those are direct impacts
of the covert pandemic
or sometimes indirect knock-on effects
for example from
delays to our modernization plans so
there is actually a key
difference of principle and and that is
i think why
um graham has explained that the the
amendment is not prudent so it was
really important to clarify
that i also wanted to come back to
cancer dr barkley
and on the green verges and cancer dr
barkley was explaining this as if it was
reducing our maintenance of the verges
we have to admit that what has been
called maintenance was actually
destruction
and residents have been paying through
their taxes to actually damage our
environment and reduce the amount of
wildlife we have here in trafford
so these changes are about restoring our
green spaces
they're about creating wildlife havens
and restoring
flower-rich habitats that cheer people
up and that we all want to see
it's about using also crucially using
our green spaces to absolutely maximize
their carbon reduction um opportunities
and to decrease pollution
so it's completely wrong to call this a
lack of maintenance this is actually
proper stewardship and what we have seen
in the past has been vandalism
[Music]
i want to talk a little bit just briefly
again about who's being impacted
and we've heard others say tonight you
know that
nobody wants to vote for an austerity
budget and
and i think we very much feel that in
the green group having not voted for
them in the past
and i wanted to just mention something
which hasn't been brought up which is
about who pays
for the things that we don't fund and so
any budget changes we can ask what is
the cost
and who pays that cost well at the
moment the traffic council taxpayer is
paying most of these costs
but we can also say what's the cost of
not doing things and who pays those
costs
and we know that when the public sector
is underfunded as it has been
desperately badly underfunded by this
government and the previous
um lib dem conservative coalition for
the last 11 years this
disproportionately affects women
so whatever important work is not paid
for is still done
and it's the difference is it's done by
free and it's done usually
by women and this is often to the
detriment of their own careers
crucially their pensions their free time
and in many cases their physical and
mental health
so i really wanted to just bring that
out the element of of
one of the one of the many many damages
of the
the austerity program we have seen that
we really need to to just acknowledge
tonight
next year we will have to make another
budget and we will be
one year further into the seven years
that we know we have left in our
carbon budget and we have to acknowledge
and i really need the other parties to
start thinking about this
that we cannot have infinite growth on a
finite planet
our precious resources are running out
we're
polluting our world irrevocably and we
need
to keep the fossil fuels that we have in
the ground
we need the council's attitude to the
airport and
to the pension scheme to change
we cannot keep our financial reliance on
the airport given that we
must reduce its use and the hundreds and
millions of our attack
of our pension funds that are going to
the biggest most polluting companies
in the world it's just unforgivable and
something that could be changed quickly
and easily
it's not in tonight's budget but it's
something that we have to raise every
time we're thinking about how we spend
our money
so we will vote for this budget tonight
not because we agree with everything in
it
not because we are giving the council a
clean bill of health
but because as i said earlier at times
of great crisis
we need to look and the issues focus on
the issues where we agree
thank you thank you councillor coggins
um councillor new grush can we have your
closing comments please
thank you mr mayor i'll try and keep
this brief
um the council group leaders
are fully aware the immense detrimental
impact covid has had on trafford
finances
we are aware too that these pressures
are not going to significantly ease in
the coming year
but i think it is crystal clear the
reason why this budget
is a a less for more budget
it it is the reason that we have not had
adequate central government
funding to support the covert pressures
and we really do need to address this
under funding issue it has to be
honestly addressed in the coming years
and if not this council is going to be
in serious
serious problems so
the liberal democrat group reluctantly
will be supporting this budget
for the same reason that we've just
heard that
it is the best we can do in the
situation that we're currently in
and we have to support that thank you
thank you councilman new grosh um
councillor evans can we have your
closing remark just to remind you you
have five minutes thank you
thank you mr mayor i'll start with there
three thank yous
uh thank you uh to nicki bishop graham
bentley and the whole team
i know every year it's an incredible
effort and i suspect this year
um it's been worse or harder than ever
so thank you for all the effort that you
do put
in and just picking up on councillor
harding
diane eaton and her team i don't think
i've ever had occasion to thank
an open council but actually the job
they have done this year has been
phenomenal uh so i must lay that on on
record
um on a slightly lighter note i thank
uh the labor group for adding in the
city of trees
from our amendment and so that is
appreciated
and i need to go on record on behalf of
the conservative group we're thanking
all the staff
um at the council everyone who has
continued to deliver essential services
to our residents during this time and
it's been truly hard
the amazing work of the teams and
volunteers across trafford who have come
out to deliver the essential vaccination
program
a short ensuring we are on the road back
to normality
as of today the country has delivered in
excess of 16 million doses
of vaccine to people my mum and dad
included two work colleagues that have
been shielding for over a year
what a magnificent achievement i want to
thank our school children and their
families for supporting them
they've done so much and we all look
forward to getting them back to school
as soon as possible
not to leave out as as i would always
bring them to the fore
the backbone of our borough the
businesses who have taken such a
battering
of this time and many of them sadly may
struggle to open again
but more to the point i want to give
thanks to the conservative government
for the amazing support it has given
to trafford the government has provided
trafford
with 177 million pounds of additional
covered funding 5.69 million
in additional on ring fence tranche
funding for 21.22
3.59 million in additional surge
funding 4.8 million for adult
social care infection control and rapid
testing
1.86 million through sales fees
and charges compensation scheme 1.56
million through the council tax
hardship fund 43.74 million
through the small business grant fund
and retail hospitality and leisure
grants funds
2.38 million in addition additional
discretionary grant funding for small
businesses which i'm sorry to say has
gone out has not gone out fast enough
and although the criteria has been
widened it should have been more
accessible
earlier 18 million in local restrictions
support grant 1.2 million in culture
recovery fund
1 949 laptops and 118 4g
routers with more on the way and also
thanks to the traffic businesses for
i know at least 300 donated to the local
children
winter fuel package 600 000 pounds
supporting families and vulnerable avid
adults so throughout the covid
uh crisis the conservative government
has continued to roll down
and brownfield funding including three
million pound for sale square
future high street fund for stratford of
17.6 million
across gm there has been 10 million
green home grant
10 million pounds worth of green home
grants to support
fuel poor residents 80 million pound for
gm for green grant funding to support
public buildings for retrofitting of
insulation and millions more in the
pipeline confirmed
and in the pipeline all part of the
government's green agenda and carbon
neutral plans
for 2050. on top of this we have
received millions in greater manchester
to keep our buses running and i thank
the minister charlotte there
for her intervention back in april
the active travel grant funding for
trafford from the conservative
government poorly delivered
speculatively causing more heartache
than joy
with the a56 covered in 181
thousand pounds worth of plastic cones
that caused more congestion and didn't
offer any meaningful outcomes
for cyclists or other road users
bollards in daydream that cost
46 000 pounds half of which were removed
within 14 days
and the other half hated by residents
even now we have residents in longford
ward who have planters shoved upon them
and then a sham of a second consultation
at who knows what cost
hail and sale more place plans poorly
delivered and again
caused great concern to residents and
businesses
a copy and paste job bearing no relation
to any consultation
the whole process now needing to be
re-run at council tax
payers expense our borrowing
capabilities
up to half a billion pounds failure to
develop vast swathes of empty premises
is of great concern to members and
residents who will eventually
pick up the bill i was going to finish
here
and welcoming the saving of our civic
buildings
but after tonight's uh exec
and the asset disposal register i have
severe doubts
about what might come from that so
members i urge you to vote against this
budget and let's go back and look at it
again thank you
mr mayor
thank you councillor evans um
councillor andrew weston has agreed at
the beginning as agreed at the beginning
of the meeting
you now have a maximum of 15 minutes to
wind up the debate
councillor weston please um
thank you mr mayor i'll begin with some
general comments about the impact that
kobed has had
on our budget and councillor ross and
indeed a number of speakers
from multiple different parties actually
have referenced this tonight but we were
promised
and we should all remember this whatever
it takes
to meet the cost of covid that this
council
you know was was impacted by and this
year
trafford council the current financial
year 2021
has spent 51.2 million
pounds more than anticipated
what have we received from government
you ask 37
million pounds and so there from the
outset
we can see that whatever it takes was
nothing but hyperbole and conservative
members
can list as many different grants as
they like
but this is just fact and it is against
that backdrop
that we have had to attempt to set a
budget for 21
22 because councils after 10 years of
being ravaged by austerity are simply
not equipped mr mayor to even begin
to absorb 14 million pounds worth of
financial hit
without the government stepping in to
help and of course it doesn't stop there
because in 2122 we face a 25 million
pound plus
funding gap much of it attributable to
covid
and so we have had to make difficult
choices
no question and we've heard from a
number of tory members tonight listing
that government support
to local authorities but it isn't close
to covering it
because when we look at how the
government have really helped us
to close this gap it's a sad tale
mr mayor it is a tale of freezing
staff pay increasing council tax
increasing the threshold
by which we can increase council tax and
allowing us to spread our covered debts
over three years drawing out the
disastrous
year that we have had and impacting on
future budgets
that isn't whatever it takes mr mayor
that is
we won't help you so your residents will
have to bear the costs
instead but even outside of covered mr
mayor
this government keeps on clobbering
local authorities because
more than 10 years of austerity have
decimated
local authority budgets more than 15
billion pounds
of funding for allies cut in that time
60 pence in the pound gone from local
government budgets
and what about more specifically where
is the sustainable
funding for adult social care where is
that white paper
where is the at least medium if not
long-term funding settlement that allows
us to effectively plan our way through
this funding madness
nowhere to be seen mr mayor instead this
year more than ever
a series of erratic and haphazard
funding announcements
moving the goal posts each and every
week
or so it has help has felt for those of
us at the sharp end
and here we are today just to add insult
to injury
the night before the budget setting not
just for us
but for dozens of councils in this
country hit by a 1.15 million pound cut
to our capital budget it really is
dire and it really does show the
disregard
that these tories in government have for
local
authorities and it's against that
backdrop of uncertainty
of rising costs of cuts that we have
trafford's conservatives
come along this evening and ask us to
fritter away
another six hundred and thirty seven
thousand pounds of reserves
on a one year reprieve or services
because let's be right mr mayor if they
were serious about protecting these
services
they wouldn't have done a shopping list
as we've received tonight
they'd have come up with some actual
alternative savings
they know this is not credible and
turning to some of the specific
comments that we heard mr mayor
councillor evans
a well-costed alternative not
in the view of the section 1-5 officer
not
well-costed mr mayor not prudent
we heard multiple conservative members
talking about lost
road and it's worth members knowing that
the cost to the council of lostop road
will be zero because the costs are being
recovered
from amy so the 46 000 pound figure
being peddled
is untrue and let us set the record
straight
councilman myers disagrees with us
raising council tax
and yet it's tory government policy to
plug
covered funding gaps with council tax
and they can't be
bothered to include that in their
alternative because they know
the council can't afford the 5 million
pound
cost we heard that council tax had gone
up by 11.5
since 2018 and that's correct it has
but actually until this year we've been
operating under your medium term
financial strategy
meaning that in 2019 20 and 20 2021
we increased council tax by the same
amount that you're
on the record as saying that you would
have increased council tax
so let's be right two years where we did
what you've said you'll do
and then one year where your government
has told us to increase it
i really don't think your position is
credible
and as for the shopping list that you've
come up with tonight
it's just it's frankly pathetic it's not
mature it's not responsible it's not
fiscally prudent we've been told that
and all it shows is that you cannot do
difficult things you're not fit for
office you're abdicating your
responsibility
and you're attempting to write your
election leaflets
and you know when councilor anthony
someone who really should know better
comes in to tell us that we can just
spend these extra reserves because the
labour administration
are using lots of reserves well as
councillor coggins neatly
articulated mr mayor our reserves
are being used for what reserves are for
emergency circumstances to cover
the cost of covid and when he says that
we're kicking the cam down the road
what on earth is failing to make these
cuts
difficult cuts things that we may not
have chosen to do
in normal circumstances in some cases
but
what is the conservative offer other
than to say
we don't like these cuts mr mayor so
we'll make them next year instead
because this year
we'll cover it through capital from
reserves not ongoing
revenue savings it's deeply
disappointing and as for the further
spread
of the cost of cobit over three years
councillor and state that's kicking the
can down the road
and that's government policy rather than
give us
the money they've said spread it over
three years and bear the cost
that way well thank you very much
national conservatives
and you know so when we hear councillor
holden objecting to the home to school
transport proposals
saying that it's an affront to parental
choice
are you suggesting that the fact that
you never had this policy
in place for high schools was an affront
to the parental choice of parents who
wanted to send children
to different high schools because all
this is doing is leveling
the playing field it will not put
grammar schools out of business and it
certainly won't stop any child from
going to grammar school because the
poorest
children will still be able to access
their home to school transport provision
and so ultimately where we're left is an
improvement amendment
not really fit to have been brought to
the chamber
at all but i have to say actually i i
consider it
quite light i was hoping for more to be
truthful and the reason that i was
hoping
for so much more mr mayor was the
delight
that is the conservatives of trafford's
plan
for our borough the one that they're
shoving through residents doors
at the moment in the post their plan for
trafford
and if anybody's not seen it if you want
to understand what they're telling
residents they'll do outside of this
chamber
rather than what they actually come in
this chamber and try to do
in practice if you want to understand
how they're misleading local residents
i'd recommend having a look at the about
us section on the tory website
keep council tax low is a key priority
and indeed they've got candidates
shoving stuff through doors saying that
council tax should not be increased
well they've not bothered to cover that
in their amendment so we can only assume
they think it has to go up
they talk about delivering more bobbies
on the street but they've complained
about the increase
in policing precepts which will put more
bobbies on the beat
they want to spend two and a half
million pounds on weekly grade bing
collections
collections that they scrapped in the
first place mr man and yet
no no recognition of the 2.5 million
pounds that that would cost a year
or indeed inclusion in their alternative
budget tonight they say they'll deliver
outstanding social care
but no criticism of the government's
lack of the paper on sustainable funding
for social care
they say that they'll ensure a home
building strategy for the borough
but they oppose the gms f they say they
go on to say
that they will lead on reducing air
pollution that's a laugh
they oppose the greater manchester clean
air plan which is their
government's policy they talk about
investing to rid the borough
of potholes and yet here we are with no
alternative budget
that increased the spend on potholes a
meaningful cycling strategy
that's a laugh we've just heard them
complain about the cycling strategy
and suggest that we've burnt 46 thousand
pounds on lost road
which in fact is not the case and the
costs are being recouped
not only are the costs being recouped
but actually
bollards are reusable councillor evans
councilman morgan councillor holden and
others who reference that
they will be used elsewhere but even
still
that cost will not be ours they then say
that they will produce a balanced budget
and again that's a cracker because here
we have one that the 151 officer has
suggested is not prudent
like the one from two years ago and
never ever forget
they left as an overspending budget and
a six hundred thousand pound gap
in the send fund so you know the
position that i'm in with this
is one of significant disappointment
because i can cope
with constructive opposition i can cope
with alternative budgets
what i can't cope with is the sort of
fake news that epitomizes councillor
evans
approach to leading the opposition
saying one thing in his leaflets and
then coming into this meeting with an
alternative budget
that doesn't go anywhere near the 10
million pound
rough estimated cost of his proposals
because of course the final proposal is
a further 400
000 pounds offering free parking for two
hours in our town centres
the challenge there is the number of
times that local tories voted
to increase parking charges when they
were in control
and indeed the fact that they've not
included
that in their alternative budget either
so let's return to the realms of reality
mr mayor because i will make it my
business to ensure that the residents of
trafford
know of the fake news the nonsense and
the misleading tactics
of our tories tell residents what
they're really about and
show residents what they're really about
with their performance this evening
but i do want to return to reality and
the very challenging budget that we face
this evening
and i want to start by thanking our
staff
these are incredibly difficult times and
our staff have
stepped up in so many different ways as
colleagues have neatly
articulated and we recognize that
and i know that it will continue to be a
stretch for them
in the next year too but i particularly
want to thank
the leadership of sarah todd and all of
our corporate directors and in
particular
nikki and graham and the finance team
more generally it gets harder every year
but this
is genuinely the worst budget i've ever
had to be involved in putting together
and i really hope it is the worst one
that the borough
ever has to bring forward but there are
positives and i want to highlight just
some
of the priorities that this budget
underpins
in terms of setting out the labour
groups agenda
more money for children's services and
whilst i'm very grateful to council and
new gross for his support
both in his speech and with the support
of his group this evening i do need to
correct him that we are spending almost
1 million pounds more
on children's services this year that
includes more money for education in
early years more money for the youth
offending service
and more money for early health three
and a half million more
for adult social care including 337
000 pounds more for public health at
such a critical time
and almost 20 percent increase to our
arts and culture budget
120 000 more for the music service and
then turning to capital
some significant investment in that
33.75 million
over three years for our schools
including i'm particularly proud the
hydrotherapy pool for delaware school
and investment in small specialist
classes a further 400 paid for
children's services
improving provision at the hayes water
center making improvements to foster
carers accommodation
and further investments at kindle lodge
children's school
turning to place millions for public
realm in stratford and ultra income
money from walking and cycling to make
similar improvements
in sale and increased funding for
business loans alongside the delivery of
full
fiverr also and councillor coppins
mentioned this and i don't always agree
that we're direct to this given that i
led greater manchester's bid for 80
million pounds
of funding for the decarbonisation of
public buildings but i'm proud that
there's 4.3 million going in there
along with improvements at ultraman
driving range sale waterside 10 million
for insulated transport schemes and the
walking
cycling fund and five million for
highways i could go on
mr mayor but i'll finish by saying this
i'm grateful to the constructive
um way in which the liberal democrat
group and the green group have
approached this
this evening that is right in the
circumstances
and you know this budget continues to do
what matters to us most protecting
frontline services
again no libraries no school crossing
patrols no children centres shut by this
administration
and millions of pounds more for
vulnerable children and for adult social
care
i might not be overjoyed by all of this
budget budgets contact
content mr mayor but i can say i'm
mighty proud of where we've got to in
the circumstances our third budget as an
administration
again a balanced budget again one that
protects services and looks out for the
most vulnerable and i hope all members
will support
thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor weston the
resolutions set out
on the reports as altered with the
agreement of council
have been moved and seconded i will now
move to the vote
and remind you that strategic
regulations require votes
on the budget are recorded please could
i now ask you to cast your vote by
pressing either four
against or abstain once the vote appears
on your screen
ensuring that you then press submit
um
okay thank you everybody that motion has
been carried
the motion has been carried and that
concludes the meeting
and can i thank you for your attendance
and hope that you enjoyed the rest of
your evening
good night everybody thank you mr mayor
bye thank you thank you